[Music]
christina is in uh los angeles christina
welcome to the ramsay show
hi george hi rachel um my question is
that my husband and i are debating
whether to purchase a house
i love a good debate
yeah
what's the debate about kind of
um i don't think we can afford it that's
my issue
we live in a one-bedroom apartment
i'm pregnant
um so it's a single-family income
my husband's take-home is about 5000 a
month
okay and
we have no debt thankfully and we have
70 000 in savings but the house is
around here
for just a two bed one bath is about
380.
yeah i mean you're in a you're in a
you're in la right
uh we're just outside but it's still
just as expensive
yeah it's southern california so your
your take-home pay is five grand total
and that's probably not changing anytime
soon
no it doesn't seem to be changing
anytime soon
okay well the parameters we recommend
and i'll tell you why we recommend them
is to stick to a 15-year fixed rate
mortgage where the mortgage payment is
no more than a quarter of your take-home
pay so in this instance you'd be looking
at trying to get your payment to around
1250 on a 15-year fixed now if you if
you do the math on that you're going
okay well that means we can afford
nothing in in the los angeles area and
so what that means to me is exactly what
i was thinking what that means to me is
you just need to buy yourself some
patience and it may mean that we need a
bigger down payment so you said you had
70 right
we had 70 we don't have enough for the
20 and to avoid the pmi yeah
my husband wants to do a 30-year fix but
i
following the steps he's fairly new to
them um i'm i would want the 15 year
sure but that means staying in our tiny
apartment which is about 450 square feet
with a baby on the way yeah is there is
there any other move that you could make
that is more lateral that could get you
more room maybe you're further outside
of the city where's his work in
proximity to all this
well he was commuting in downtown l.a
and the commute was killing him
um he works in downtown l.a
he was he found a new job closer but
it's the same pay
so we'll be saving uh on transportation
but he we really don't want to want him
to commute anymore yeah it was just too
rough yep
and this is one of the hard things i
feel like
depending on where you live because
there's just certain
parts of the country you know that it's
it's going to be more expensive and so
the reason we have these parameters and
and we always kind of laugh not to poke
fun of california but we're always like
just because you live in california
doesn't mean you're exempt from math so
the formula still works no matter where
you live
um is what george is saying it's either
going to just take more time and and how
old are you guys
uh we're 34 35 okay we're having our
first child awesome well congratulations
unexpecting that's very exciting very
very exciting so yeah i mean i
i would always say you don't have one or
two it's not like we can buy a house we
can't buy a house and we have to stay in
this one bedroom and that's it you have
other options so you guys i would shop
around and even if it adds an extra
15-20 minutes to go and rent a
two-bedroom give yourself a little bit
more space if it's in the budget you're
able to spread out a little bit more if
you can uh especially what that may be
coming and then you guys have a game
plan to say okay you know what our goal
is in the next
i don't know what it is for you guys
maybe it's five years maybe it's maybe
it's eight years that we're going to buy
a home but because of the part of the
country you're in it is more expensive
and
again you guys are making you know
you're making 60 000
um
which is great uh but it but again equal
to the standard of living
and the expenses in somewhere like
southern california it goes quickly um
that money does so
you guys want this house when you decide
to purchase because i always encourage
home ownership to get to a point where
you guys can do this because it's just a
great investment i think it's i think
it's something that's really wise to put
your money towards um
but
you guys it needs to be a blessing not a
curse and when you stretch yourself so
thin
um it starts to be that curse so set
yourself up and just have patience and
listen if you're renting again even if
it's for five more years you're not
throwing money down the drain you're
setting yourself up to be wise but it's
going to take a lot of patience
christina
and and i and i know starting a family
and all that it's going to make you want
to have a home even that much more
but listen let the money and the numbers
be there and
again i hate to say it you guys aren't
exempt from math but it does kind of
stink when you talk to someone who's in
miami or up in the northeast or southern
california because it is what it is that
real estate is just it's more expensive
christina pop over to
ramseysolutions.com and click on
mortgage calculator that's what i was
doing over here just to try to see where
you guys would need to be at and it
looks like you just need to say keep
saving up that down payment i know 70
000 is amazing you might need 120 you
might need 130 in order to get a house
in your area that's within your budget
you can also have your husband listen to
our fine print episode is now the worst
time to buy a house rachel cruz was
featured on there and she talks through
the green lights of what it would take
to get into that house so it's the
perfect episode for him to check out you
can go to fineprintpodcast.com
and search for that episode listen to it
with him and maybe it'll slow him down
and go all right you're right we got to
do this thing the right way so the house
is a blessing not a curse this is the
ramsay show